Okay welcome back to Gary's Economics
today we are going to teach you
how to argue with your friends
about wealth taxes.
Okay so we are filming this in early August 2025
in an exceptionally exciting time to be an economist
to be involved in global economics
global politics
All of the traditional political parties
all over the world are dying
that's happening all across Europe
it's happening here in the UK as well
we've just seen probably the
the death of the Conservative Party
coming up very soon.
Labour Party in power are very unpopular
all of the traditional
political parties are super unpopular
and that is because
it is becoming increasingly obvious to everybody
that the economic status quo is not working.
What that means is
there is a phenomenal opportunity now to decide
as a society which way our economies are going to go
everybody knows this, the billionaires know it
that's why they are aggressively funding the far right
and that is why the far right is moving ahead
in this debate of how we shift our economy
but it doesn't have to go that way
a lot of people don't like the far right ideas
they don't like anti immigrant
anti foreigner ideas and there is a massive
massive space to basically take possession of
of this argent basically
the old ideas about the economy are dying
and the new ideas are yet to be born
and I think we are in a great position
to dominate
the conversation about the economy going forward
I think we're in this interesting space
where kind of
the economic status quo of the last 30 years
has failed
and you have the far right coming in
and I think we are basically
probably the best positioned guys to compete with them
but what we don't have is the billionaire
funding of the far right so
what I am depending on
is a kind of different model of how to educate people
how to win people over which is I educate you
you understand the economics of the situation
as fully as possible
and you use that understanding to educate your friends
and educate your family
we are using a human amplification model
I suppose as opposed to the billionaire
and the money amplification model
which is used by the main political parties
and also by the far right media
but I think we can win
but in order to do that
you need to know how to speak to your friends
and your family about economics
about wealth taxes about billionaires
about inequality so that we can spread these ideas
and we can dominate the conversation
and then we can win over politics
and the economic situation in this country
and in yours.
So I'm gonna break this down into kind of a checklist
basically so
you understand all of the most important things
about how to convince your friends and family
about the importance of managing inequality
about the importance of wealth taxes
and No. 1 on the list is don't be a dick
So don't be a dick is about not
basically trying to force your
opinions about inequality and wealth
taxes on your friends and your family
in an aggressive way. I think in
our culture we have this kind of idea
that the way to persuade somebody of something is
to have a debate with them
you see this all over the internet
you see this all over YouTube
with this guy destroys that guy
it's totally the dominant like media narrative
the media form of of how to discuss economics
is we have the left wing guy
we have the right wing guy
they fight each other to the death
and somehow that persuades people
basically having
done this work of persuading people on the economy
for many years now I'm convinced that debates are
almost never convince anyone of
of anything and they're just not a good way
to persuade people of things
the first thing is
you need to recognize where we are
as an economy and as a society
and again this is relevant for the UK and
and for every other western country
living standards are falling quite quickly
people's children and
grandchildren are and will be much poorer than
than they are or they were
and that is scary you know
you know that is scary
we're here in 2025 in most of the western world
we haven't experienced like
really widespread poverty for a long time
and we're moving into widespread poverty
and that's scary
and people are scared and people are stressed out
people don't know why it's happening
people don't know what to believe and
yeah people are scared
people are told the problem is foreigners
people are told the problem is immigrants and really
there's not a lot of good economics education
people are running around
they're scared and they're worried
and if you wanna speak to them
you need to understand that
and if you come in aggressively
if you force people into a debate
they don't wanna have
if you shout people down
if you try and win debates against people
you're probably just gonna force people
kind of further
into their own echo chamber
into their own thoughts
into their own sort of spaces
of fear and I think when people are scared
it's just really really difficult to move people
into a positive space
if we're gonna fix this
it's gonna have to be through sort of building
unity between the middle class and the working class
and I don't think we're gonna achieve that
by shouting at each other
so the key thing, number one
don't be a dick
understand that different people are
in different situations
here in the UK recently we've had a lot of recent
like far right protests at hotels of
refugees and this kind of thing and
there has been obviously
like counter protests where people on the left go
and sort of shout at them and
you know I understand that
I understand people on the left wanna protect refugees
wanna protect immigrants
it's important to recognise that
people who might not be on the same side as you
are scared and they're
in an economically difficult situation
and in many cases
they're struggling to look after their kids
they're worried about their kids' futures
they're being told the problem is foreigners
they're being told the problem is immigrants
I think the problem is growing inequality
I think the problem is billionaires
but you're not gonna persuade these people
just by going down and shouting at them
you need to be able to to be compassionate
to people who are in different situations
than you
that means
they might be getting different ideas from the media
they might be in different financial positions
When I talk about the economy
I'm always very aware that I am a rich person
I don't need to worry about paying the bills
if I'm talking to somebody who's not in that situation
I need to recognize that
they're in a different position
if you're a poor person
and you're talking to a richer person
you need to recognise
when you're talking about things like
taxing the rich they're gonna be scared
you're thinking about taxing them
the situation of a poor person is super different
to the middle class obviously
the middle class don't have this problem
of worrying about paying the bills
of worrying about feeding their kids
but the middle class is also being squeezed here
they're worried about things like
will my kids
be able to live the same kind of life that I did
will my kids be able to afford a home
will my kids be able to afford a family
if you can't understand with a bit of compassion
the position of people
who might be in a different situation than you
you're never gonna persuade anyone so that's it
have a little bit of understanding
have a little bit of thoughtfulness
don't force conversations on people you don't want to
On that subject of forcing conversations
I think it's important just to recognise
when is the right place
and when is the right person to try to have like
a productive educational conversation
these kinds of things
because No. 1 if you
go home and and try and argue with
your right wing dad or uncle
at Christmas when they don't want the conversation
all you're gonna do is build division
it's not really gonna help
but also recognize
especially with things like arguments online
that sometimes
people who have no interest in listening to you
or understanding
you are just trying to drag you into a fight
and waste your time, wait for the right opportunity
wait for the right people
wait for the right time, try and find times and spaces
where you can really have a conversation
that takes the kind of
morality out of it takes the politics out of it
and just explains very clearly
very educationally what is happening
I think that's the best way
to understand and that brings us on to point 2
which is understanding and education
so I'm a big believer that the best way to
persuade somebody of something
is to explain it very clearly
We are in a situation now where 70
80, 90% of people in this country and in your country
their kids and their grandkids
will live in desperate poverty
first take a little bit of time to sit with that
because that's a f**ked up situation
but also recognise that unless that means
unless you're talking to a very rich person
the person you are speaking to
has a strong self
interest for the future of their family
to agree with you
you should be coming into this debate in a situation
that what your aim is
is to protect your kids from poverty
and to protect their kids from poverty
that is the truth of the situation here
for 90% of the people in the country
the working class and the middle class
unless you can unite do something
about growing inequality
you will not be able to protect your kids from poverty
so your base stance for any
I'm not gonna use the term debate
because I don't think debates help
for any conversation about the economy should be
if we don't do something
both my kids and your kids will live in poverty
so we need to do something about that
and your your main goal should be to very
very clearly explain that point
because if you can explain that point clearly
then it's not gonna be about left or right
it's not gonna be about morality
it's gonna be about the very clear
shared interest that you have
with most of the other people in your country
of protecting your kids and your grandkids from poverty
Okay so how do you effectively
clearly educate the people you are talking to
to make it clear to them
that you're trying to protect their kids from poverty
that in my opinion
is all about understanding
the best way to educate and explain a concept
in my opinion
is to understand it as clearly as possible yourself
and that is why here on this channel
I try as much as I can
to do a lot of educational videos about the economy
and I really
really try to make it as clear as possible to hopefully
you the viewer
the thing that I'm trying to explain so part of the
my philosophy on YouTube of education is I
don't ever have scripts for these videos
maybe that's obvious. I plan the videos
but I never script them I'm not reading an autocue here
the reason I do that is
because I think the best way to educate somebody
else of a thing is to really
really really understand that thing
so during the weeks when I'm planning these videos
rather than writing a script
I'm just trying my best to really understand
the situation and the concepts
and my idea is, my belief is
if you come into a situation
with a complete understanding of
of what is happening
then you should be able to explain it
without needing to read off of a script
and I think that
I think that that comes through better
that educates better and that actually communicates
the understanding better so that means
if you want to explain to people that
if they want to protect their kids
and protect their grandkids from poverty
they need to care about the wealth distribution
care about inequality care about the tax system
shift the tax burden to the rich
you firstly
need to understand that very clearly yourself
and hopefully
if you've been watching this channel for a long time
you should be able to do that because really
like my No. 1 aim, absolute No. 1 priority
aim from this channel is to reach a situation
where the vast majority of the working class
and the middle class can understand
in simple terms
why changing the tax system
is essential for protecting the financial position
of their family
the financial position of the kids and their grandkids
in case you haven't fully fully understood that by now
I'm gonna mention a few of the videos on this channel
also one on another channel
which I think are probably the best videos to watch
if you wanna understand that very simple concept
so the first one is we have got a video series
understanding the economy
which I think is three or maybe four videos now
which really explains ground up why inequality matters
why people don't talk about it enough
why it's important to protect
your family's financial position
if you wanna watch just one video
I think ‘The Squeeze Out’ is is probably the best
I think it's
possibly the best video we've ever done on the channel
in just, in just really
really simply explaining that we have an economy
which has a small group of super rich
that are aggressively expanding their wealth share
and in doing so
they are basically out competing one at a time
every other group in society
and squeezing
the wealth out of other groups in society
and what that means is
the working class loses their wealth
the government loses their wealth
the working class goes into debt
the government goes into debt
and we are moving into the stage now
where the middle class starts to get squeezed out
as well. I think that video
The Squeeze Out
really explains really clearly this basic concept
which is you cannot have one group
even if it is a tiny number of people rapidly
aggressively
in a kind of compound exponential accelerating fashion
aggressively expanding their wealth share
in a finite economy which is not growing quickly
which has finite resources
if you have a section of an economy
exponentially growing in a finite economy
eventually that group of society will own everything
and what that means is nobody else
including your kids including your grandkids
including your government will own anything
and I often use the metaphor of a cancer
because really what this is
is exactly a cancer what you have is a group of society
that is aggressively
when a cancer starts is very small right
but the problem with cancer is it grows very quickly
it grows at an exponential rate
so when it starts growing
it's growing but then it starts to grow super
super quickly and relatively quickly
it takes over the entire host and it destroys the host
and this is what the very rich will do in our society
if untreated
so I think The Squeeze Out is a great video
The understanding the economy series is a great video
we'll link all of these in the comments
I also think the
if you want like a really short one
I think the interview I did
with Krishnan Guru Murphy
at Channel 4 is another really good
like basic description
but really the whole
everything on this channel is about
trying to educate you very clearly
on these simple concepts these very
very simple concepts. If you do not deal
with the aggressive wealth growth of the very rich
their share will grow and grow in an exponential way
exponential growth gets out of control very
very quickly
it will rapidly displace
all of the other wealth in society
your governments will break down
because their wealth will be lost
and the middle class
and the working class will also break down
and that is why you need to deal with it
so understand this simple concept
and I think it's important to recognize
when you deal with this
we exist in a political climate where a big strategy
which the
the far right or the billionaires use against me
is they point at me and they say
Gary's a communist, Gary's on the far left
and they demonize anything that is considered left
so personally I don't think this is
a left wing idea my background is not in politics
my background is in economics
my background is trading
I use these ideas to make a lot of money
trading financial markets
for me
this is like like car mechanics
you know a car mechanic looks at your car
he points out the problem
a doctor looks at your body you've got cancer
I'm an economist I can see what you have
the problem is a
rapid growth of wealth in this tiny little group
this is not a left wing idea
this is a do you want your kids to be poor idea
and I think that is an important
starting ground to work from
just make it really really clear
communicate to people that
the way that this is often portrayed
as a kind of temporary recession
is increasingly obviously untrue
something else is happening
what is happening is aggressive wealth concentration
amongst the very rich
that is squeezing other groups out of society
what that means is wealth owning becomes impossible
for other groups in society
what that means practically
is your kids cannot have a house okay
and now we're moving on
I think to the the most common kickbacks
Alright so now I'm going to address some of the main
push backs against the idea that we need to tax
the very rich, that we need to tax wealth not work
and I'm just gonna go through one after another
most of these already covered before on the channel
but it's nice to have them all in one place
I think
and we keep getting asked the same questions again
and again
The most common push back we get by a million miles is
you can't tax them, if you tax them they'll leave and
what this misunderstands is and this is a very
very common criticism
what I do is a kind of sometimes intentional
sometimes accidental misunderstanding of
I'm trying to tax
people who own an enormous amount of wealth
I'm not trying to tax high earning individuals
that's why we chose to use the slogan tax wealth
not work we live in a tax system
which already taxes high earning individuals
very highly it does not tax extremely wealthy families
or individuals very highly at all
so working people are gonna be paying 50
60% maybe more if you include everything
whereas billionaires are often paying 0%
this is an absurd tax system
so we're not trying to tax
first thing is to make it very clear
we're not trying to tax working people in fact
we wanna reduce tax on working people
we're trying to tax the billionaires
the super super rich
and this is relevant to the idea of if you tax them
they leave because if you try and tax a working person
like a doctor or a lawyer or a Youtuber
then that person can very often move to Dubai
or move to Singapore
and they can do their job in the other country
they can pay tax in the other country
which might be at a lower rate
they can avoid the tax
if we're talking about taxing billionaires
they don't make their money from their work
they get their money from owning assets
and assets means property
assets means land, assets means natural resources
assets means government debt
it means your mortgage
it means businesses that sell to the west
these guys they own largely property and debt
I think one way to think about it is if I have an asset
I get a passive income, where does that income come from
so if I own British businesses
it comes from British consumers
if I own British debt it comes from British mortgagees
people have mortgages, if I own British government debt
it comes from the British taxpayer
if I own British property
it comes from British renters
you know and the same is true all over the west
so if I own a ton of British assets
and I tried to move to Dubai
I'm still taking an enormous amount of cash flow
from British people
when they pay that passive income
so wealth holders can be taxed even if they leave
there's this absurd idea
oh my God, some people even start to mention
I think I'll do a brief segue here
because it's so ridiculous
some people start to mention
this idea of a Laffer Curve
about taxing taxing wealth
and the idea of a Laffer curve is
if you tax people so much
they will eventually like avoid the tax
so if you really increase tax on work
people will stop working
or people will leave the country
but if you really
if you, first of all this Laffer Curve goes up and down
so it's supposed to hit a top at like 50%
we're trying to raise tax on wealth from 0% to 2%
which is definitely not
a section which is downward sloping in this curve
how do you avoid a wealth tax
we're taxing ownership we're taxing hoarded wealth
the way that you avoid a tax on hoarded wealth
is you stop hoarding wealth
which is exactly what we want
we want the rich people to stop holding wealth
so that you can get your f**king wealth back
that's what we want, that is what we want
so we are not trying to tax working people
we are trying to cut tax on working people
we wanna attract productive people
productive businesses to the country
we wanna stop taxing ordinary working people like you
we wanna stop taxing ordinary working people
like your kids we wanna tax the super rich
let's talk about what happens
if you don't tax the super rich
their wealth grows and grows
and grows and grows and grows
and other people in society like the middle class
like the government
see their wealth shrink and shrink and shrink
and shrink and shrink eventually
the government runs out of wealth
and has a choice between
shutting the welfare state down
taxing the rich or taxing the middle class
if you do not tax the rich
you will end up taxing the middle class
we here on this channel
are the people trying to protect the middle class
if you do not tax the rich
then the middle class will be next
and you are seeing this happen
we're gonna see this happen in the UK
in the budget this autumn
you are gonna see
because of the government's unwillingness
to tax the super rich that the middle class get taxed
you are seeing this at the moment with Donald Trump
in the US he is cutting tax on billionaires
and he is moving towards consumption taxes
which is tax on the middle class
Listen...
the billionaires are gonna try to tell you that
when I say tax the billionaires
I mean tax you at the same time
the billionaires are actively raising your taxes
if you want to protect your kids and your wealth
and your tax rates you need to protect yourselves
from the people who are going to take your wealth
which is the billionaires
now this is related to to the next point
which I'll just cover quickly
which is taxing rich people is really
really hard so we shouldn't do it
I agree taxing rich people is is super super hard
I think the main reason
taxing rich people is super hard
is because they have so much power
and influence over the media
and over politicians but I think we
we have a chance of doing it
and I think if we don't do it
then our economy will collapse
so I think it's worth
it's worth doing it to avoid our country collapsing
listen, our grandparents
and our great grandparents lived in desperate poverty
and they fought hard to make things better
and they did make things better
if you don't fight hard to protect the working classes
the middle classes then you lose the middle class
and you lose your wealth
just because something is difficult
that doesn't mean it's not worth doing
a country which refuses to do difficult
but essential things collapses, listen
curing cancer is difficult but if you had cancer
would you wanna try and cure it
or would you wanna just try and let it take control
it's worth doing
I'm gonna keep fighting so you should fight too okay
so the next argument against this
which is common is that it's not fair
it's not fair to tax rich people
rich people work so hard
they they deserve all of the money that they get
okay I just wanna make it clear
I'm not trying to tax working people
I worked very hard, I paid 50
60%, at the same time
the Duke of Westminster inherited £10 billion and
paid nothing
I don't think that's very fair
we always campaign on tax wealth not work
Unless you are a billionaire
a super wealthy person we are trying to cut your taxes
listen if you wanna talk about fairness
if we do not do anything about this system
then very very quickly
the billionaires will own everything
and you will own nothing and we will move into a system
where all wealth is inherited
and it is impossible for ordinary people to own wealth
does that sound fair to you
but to be honest once again
I think this is a general
a good general piece of advice
when you're talking about persuading people
personally I don't like to focus on fairness
I like to focus on
real outcomes which is
if you don't deal
with this aggressive growth in wealth
of the very very rich
then what that means is
there will be no wealth holdings anywhere else
so whether you want fairness
or whether you want unfairness
you have a choice, do you want untaxed billionaires
or do you want your grandkids to own property
you cannot have both
you cannot have everything being owned by a minority
and things being owned by the majority
you have to choose either you tax the billionaires
or you accept poverty for your grandkids
So the last criticism we often get
and I think it's been pretty well covered now
is the misunderstanding that
I'm trying to tax working people
I'm not
I'm trying to cut your taxes
I'm trying to cut tax on working people
if you do not tax the billionaires
we will reach a situation
where the billionaires end up taxing you
that's happening now in the US
it's happening now in the UK
tax wealth not work
we are the people who are protecting the middle class
if you are in the middle class
you should be on our side,  support us
we're not trying to tax working people
we're trying to tax the super rich, look
this is if you do not tax the billionaires
then in your country just like in my country
you will reach a situation
where the only way to not shut the welfare state down
is to raise taxes on the middle class okay
we're gonna do it here
it's gonna happen in your country
it is happening now in the United States
this increase in tariffs is a tax on consumption
consumption taxes are regressive taxes
which are paid disproportionately by the middle class
we are already in this situation
the billionaires
in an attempt to protect themselves from taxes
are gonna raise your taxes
we are the group that is saying
cut taxes on working people
the billionaires
are constantly trying to tell you that
we are trying to raise your taxes
we're not
they're the guys doing it, tax wealth not work
reduce tax on working people.
Okay the next
and I think the last common criticism that we'll get
and I will say
if there are other criticisms you often get
stick them in the comments and
we will address them in another follow up video
I guess the last one I get is like
don't give money to the government
if you give money to the government
they'll waste it
governments have been basically
rapidly shut down in every country in the world
including this country
but I never said give your money to the government
what I'm doing is not about increasing government
it is not about increasing the tax take
what I'm trying to do
is protect you from aggressively growing
billionaire wealth I'm trying to change who pays taxes
at the moment
we have a situation where the super rich pay nothing
they grow their wealth massively
they squeeze out you and your family
while you and your family pay 40
50, 60% it's absurd
I'm not trying to give more money to the government
I'm trying to give more money to you and your family
I'm trying to protect your wealth
this is not about increasing government
I'm not a communist, I am the only person here
who is gonna give your kids a chance to own a home
Okay so to conclude
the situation that we're in is big and it's scary
the economic situation is gonna worsen really
really quickly, people are scared man
people are scared and people are right to be scared
it's important to understand that
when people are scared
and they see their family situation deteriorating
and they don't understand why
there's a very understandable instinctive
reflexive response
which is I wanna find the most powerful person I can
and I wanna try to get them to protect me
and if you look throughout history
you will see time and time and again
at times of serious economic deterioration
people vote for a strong man dictators
that's gonna happen now
that is gonna happen now because people are scared
in my opinion
the way to deal with fear is understanding
if people understand the situation
and how to respond to the situation
then they can act in a meaningful way
to protect their interests
while people are scared they're gonna rush to
kind of beg the protection of the billionaires
and they're gonna end up trying to be protected
by the exact people who are gonna eat their kids
so let's educate let's make things clear
let's make things clear to the public
what is happening is wealth inequality is increasing
that means the share that used to be held by you
by ordinary families by ordinary governments
is disappearing and is being held by the super rich
if you take that back you can own wealth
and you can have a good standard of living
if you don't take that back
the situation will worsen
it will grow, it will accelerate like a cancer
and your kids will live in poverty
the way to protect yourself
is to raise taxes on the super rich
so that wealth
can start flowing back to ordinary families
like yours
I know it's a lot to take in
when I first started
understanding that the economy was gonna collapse
back in 2011 I kind of had a mental breakdown
so I know like it's a big deal
but you don't have time to have a mental breakdown
right now you need to protect your kids
you need to protect your grandkids
and the way to do that is to understand the problem
and to educate your friends and your family
listen there is a massive space in politics
we can fill it. If we don't fill it
it's gonna get filled by some pretty bad guys
so support us, support the channel
understand, educate your friends
educate your family. Tax wealth
not work. Thank you very much